مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه
الجديده للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه كالعاده نستضيف
المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز الدويري وا
نتابع بدايه تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على
الخريطه التفاعليه مع سلام خضر سلام شكرا
حسن اذا اليوم تشهد عده مناطق في قطاع غزه
اشتباكات توصف بانها عنيفه وضار سنبدا من
جنوب قطاع غزه بالتحديد من منطقه خان يونس
لسببين رئيسيين الاول ضراوه المعارك التي
تشهدها خانيونس
وثانيا لان اسرائيل اعلنت انها ستسحب خمسه
الويه مقاتله تتوزع بين مشات ومظلم
ومدرعات من منطقه جنوب القطاع خان يونس لم
يدخلها بعد الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يحاصر
مدينه خانيونس هناك سبعه الويه تقاتل في
الجنوب واليوم صباحا اعلن عن الدفع بفرقه
المظليين الى تلك المنطقه القتال قاسن
ودار القوات الاسرائيليه متمركزه عند تخوم
خان يونس الضربات كانت تاتيها من اقصى شرق
القطاع شنت هجمات في خزاعه ايضا و وهناك
قتال مباشر بين جندي الى جندي بحسب ما قال
الجيش الاسرائيلي واعلنت بالطبع سرايا
القدس وباقي فصائل المقاومه عن وقوع
اشتباكات مباشره سبعه الويه من بينها
الويه نخبه منها جفعاتي ومنها كفير جفعاتي
هو لواء مقاتل كفير هو لواء هندسي مقاتل
قالت اسرائيل انه مختص بتفجير الانفاق
التي تقسمها ما بين انفاق استراتيجيه
وانفاق تكتيكيه التكتيكي مخصص للهجمات وا
استراتيجي مخصص للقياده بحسب الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه قال ان سحب هذه الالويه ياتي
في اطار ايه اعطاء الجنود المقاتلين
استراحه وكانت واحده من ال ابرز الصحف
الاسرائيليه قالت قبل ذلك ان هذه الالويه
ستساهم باعاده تدوير عجله
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي يعاني وهناك خسائر
كبيره وكلف
تدفعها اسرائيل ولكن نبقى على صعيد
الالويه منطقه الشمال شمال قطاع غزه هي
المنطقه الاولى التي بدات فيها العمليات
العسكريه سواء قصف جوي عنيف جدا او توغلات
بريه واشتباكات سنتحدث عن ابرز المعارك
طبعا هذا لا يعني ان هناك معارك متوقفه
ابدا اليوم المعارك موجوده في مثلا جباليا
جباليا انسحبت منها اسرائيل الشيخ رضوان
انسحبت منه القوات الاسرائ يه الشجاعيه لم
تعد في الشجاعيه ولكن هناك مقاومه عنيفه
حيث توجد اليه او جندي اسرائيلي بالفعل
سنتحدث بالتحديد عن الشجاعيه لسبب رئيسي
الشجاعيه هاجمها لواء جولاني الذي يوصف
بانه راس حربه الجيش الاسرائيلي تشكل قبل
قيام دوله اسرائيل هو هو شكلته مجموعه
القاده التي عملت ضمن عصابات الهاجانا
وشتيرن في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قبل قيام
الدوله هذا اللواء لواء جولاني عام
2014 وعام
2023 تكبد خسائر بالغه جدا في نقطه وحيده
في شارع هو يعتبر المدخل الشرقي لمدينه
غزه في الشجاعيه الذي لا تزيد مساحته على
2 م مربع كثير هيبه الشجاعيه تعرف بباس
مقاتليها وم هذه الخسائر انسحب لواء
جولاني ولكن للتعرف اكثر وظيفه الالويه
كيف انسحبت لماذا انسحبت معك حسن و شكرا
سلام فعلا الحديث الابرز الان سيكون في
البدايه حول انسحاب الالويه الخمسه كما
ذكرت قوات الاحتلال بينها كما قالت
المعلومات ثلاثه الويه تدريب لكن الجميع
كان يعمل في غزه يعني من حيث المبدا لا لا
تزال المعلومات ناقصه حتى نتحقق من اين
هذه الالويه ما هي المهام التي كانت مكلله
الى غير ذلك لانه ما جرى في خلال 61 62
يوم من المعركه البريه طر عليه تعديلات
جوهريه كثيره جدا خاصه بعد انتهاء المرحله
الاولى والبدء بالمرحله
الثانيه عندما كان الحديث عن المرحله
الاولى القاطع الشمالي كانت ثلاثه فرق
تقاتل في المنطقه
الشماليه من الشمال ومن الشرق ومن الوسط و
وجرى مجريات المعركه لما بدا الحديث بدات
الم المعركه الثانيه كانت تحت
مقوله توسيع العمليات تنشيط العمليات
بالتوازي نعم اي بمعنى اخر القتال في
الشمال والجنوب عندما بدا الحديث عن
المرحله الثالثه وبدات المؤشرات تشير الى
انسحابات حدثت هذه لفتره محدوده جدا
ولكن تم اتخاذ اجراء اخر وهو
اعاده تركيب البناء التنظيمي القتالي
للوحدات فتم سحب الثلاثه فرق الى اماكن
مختلفه لادوار مختلفه وتم الابقاء على
اربعه الويه حاليا يوجد في المنطقه
الشماليه او القاطع الشمالي اربعه الويه
في غرب الشيخ رضوان في غرب مخيم جباليا في
غرب مدينه جباليا في حي التفاح
و في بعض الاجزاء الاخرى جبل الريس والدرج
وما شابه ذلك و ولا يزال القتال محتدم
فيها وبنفس حده ومستوى القتال في المناطق
الوسطى
والجنوبيه عندما سحب الوحدات سحب الفرقه
المدرعه 36 الى منطقه
الوسط وكانت المهمه السيطره على منطقه
المخيمات
في البدايه حاول ان يحدث اختراق وتقسيم
البريج عن الصيرات عن الزوايده والسيطره
على الشارع صلاح الدين
فشل اجرى تعديلين جوهريين التعديل الاول
وجه الجهد الرئيسي الى منطقه مخيم البريج
وبدا يهاجم من الشمال ومن الشرق وتقديم
اسناد ناري كثيف جدا ومحاولات تقرب من
الجانب الغربي جميعها مني بالفشل ما هو
كان الخيار المساند المتزامن قام باجراء
مناوره قام باجراء مناوره من الشمال
والغرب من النصيرات كان يطمح ان يتعدى
النصيرات والزوايده ولا اطراف دير البلح
ولكنه اخفق ايضا في تلك المنطقه ولا تزال
قواته عالقه في هذه منطقه الوسط نذهب الى
الجنوب المنطقه الجنوب كما اشارت بلغ
المجموع العام سبعه الويه عززها هذا اليوم
اشارت واستخدمت مفرده فرقه هي وحده وليس
فرقه لانه فرقه تعني ثلاثه الويه هي وحده
مظليين من لواء المظليين وكانت هذه هي
اصلا تابعه للواء مظليين ارسل بالامس اي
بمعنى اخر تم ارسال لواء وعزز بكتيبه
لماذا بسبب حده الخسائر وارتفاع سقف
الخسائر ومعظمها كان في الاليات ومن اجل
اجراءات ميدانيه الان نعود الى الخمسه
الويه المجموع الكلي لهذه القوات التي
كانت مشتركه سواء في الشمال او الوسط او
في الجنوب بلغ في الحد الاقصى 17 لواء اي
بمعنى اخر ست فرق ناقص خمسه فرق زائد
لوائين الان من اين سحب هذه القوه على
سبيل المثال في منطقه القاطع الشمالي هو
اصلا سحب لوائين من الفرقه 162 اين ذهبوا
قد يكون جزء منهم سحب فرقه اخرى الى
الشمال من ذلك الى ما بعد سيدت وبالتالي
هناك عنده احتياط عملياتي عنده احتياط
استراتيجي اذا دعني اقول من الصعوبه بمكان
جمله واحده ان يكون السحب من ارض المعركه
بصوره مباشره انما سيكون بصوره تدريجيه
ويمكن انه اخذ من بعض المناطق الاخرى التي
ليس في في في حاله اشتباك حاس طيب هذا
بالنسبه ل الانسحابات
سنتطرق كالعاده لتحليل بعض المشاهد والصور
لكن قبل ذلك نود الاشاره هنا الى انه في
الحرب الحاليه برزت عبوات شواظ التي
صنعتها وطورتها كتائب القسام على مدى
سنوات لتاخذ مكانا زا في المعارك الحاليه
نتعرف على مزيد من تفاصيل هذه العبوات
وميزاتها في تقرير لصهيب العصا ثم
نعود الى ان وصلنا الى اخر عبوه وهي عبوه
شواظ قبل 20 عاما ولدت عبوه شواظ هذه
المشاهد تعود الى عام 2005 وقد كانت شواظ
قد دخلت الى الخدمه
[موسيقى]
حديثا وتها كتائب القسام من سلسله من
العبوات الناسفه وصولا الى الشكل الحالي
تزن العبوه القساميه 21 كيلو جراما وتخترق
ما بين 60 و65 سمت من الحديد المصفح على
الاليات العسكريه لكن ابرز ما يميز شواظ
هو طريقه التفجير من مسافه الصفر لتحقيق
اكبر ضرر ممكن بالاليه المستهدفه يتم
الامر بسحب صاعق التفجير وليس عبر تمديد
اسلاك او توصيل اجهزه اخرى اذ كانت
العبوات الاخرى قبل شواظ اشبه ببرميل مفخخ
مشبوك باسلاك وصواعق عن بعد لكن الامر مع
شواظ يعطي المقاتله دقه اكبر وتجنبا
للاخطاء في التمديدات او التشويش على
التوصيلات الكهربائيه هكذا تقوم شواظ
بدورها الكبير لكن ببساطه ان يلقي المقاتل
قنبله يدويه مع فارق التشبيه والوزن
والقدره التدميريه فقد تم تطوير شواظ
لتعمل بنفس طريقه القنبله اليدويه يسحب
ساعق تلقى على الهدف وتنفجر كذلك عبوه
العمل الفدائي التي تزن 3 كيلوغرامات مع
وجود مغناطيس عليها لتحقيق انفجار في نقطه
معينه في الاليه
المستهدفه اذا هو التشابه في طريقه العمل
البسيطه مع فارق القوه الانفجاريه بين
القنبله اليدويه وعبوه العمل الفدائي
وعبوه الشواف الله اكبر هكذا استطاعت
كتائب القسام ان تطور من القنبله اليدويه
المعروفه عالميا عبوتين من صنعها المحلي
بالاعتماد على نفس اليه التفجير العمل
الفدائي وشواذ لكن ثمه امر لا يصنع في ورش
التصنيع العسكري هو هذا المقاتل الذي يقرر
تنفيذ هذه العمليه اذ يجب وضع هاتين
العبوتين على الاليه مباشره لتحقيق الضرر
المطلوب وخلال ثلاث الى اربع ثوان ستكون
قد انفجرت هذا يعني ان وقت امام المنفذ
للانسحاب من من المكان فيعرض نفسه لخطر
الاصابه وربما الاستشهاد اما بشض العبوه
او بالنار المنطلقه منها مثلما هو الحال
في هذه العمليه التي نفذها مقاتل من قسام
في
غزه او هذه العمليه التي نفذها اخر في خان
يونس سريعا قبل ان يصل الى النفق كانت
العبوه قد
انفجعت هكذا تدير المقاومه الفلسطينيه
معركتها مع الجيش المتوغلة
ل من يريد ان يستخدم عبوه بهذا الشكل عليه
ان يقترب جدا من الهدف هي وعبوه العمل
الفدائي نعم وعليه ان ان يكون متقبلا
مسبقا الى درجه عاليه من الخطوره ام اي
خطا اي انسحاب متاخر قد يفضي الى استشهاد
وبالتالي هي عمل خطير جدا ومثل ما شار
التقرير هي في البدايه كانت يعني تعمل
ثلاثه طرق الطريقه الاولى بعمليات التوصيل
سواء بالاسلاك الكهربائيه او الكورتكس نعم
ال الطريقه الثانيه رقم اثنين كانت قسم
منها موجه يعني قسم لاصق وقسم موجه توضع
المتفجرات على شكل حرف في وهي مغلفه
بالنحاس نعم والاسلوب الثالث اللي هو
عمليه التنشيط الداخلي الانتير مفيش
وه ماح الان ما هي الميكانيكي قديما في
القنابل الويه التي اشار لها كان
يستخدم ما يسمى عنه
ب حشب يكون فيه الفتيل البطيء يطلق عليه
مطلق يكون في مسحوق البارود الاسود
التقليدي هذا هذا القديم جدا وعندما تسحب
يكون هناك تتولد شعله يشتعل الفتيل يعطي
ثلاثه الى اربع ثواني ومن ثم يتم
هنا لا تزال الفتره المعطيه للمنفذ
العمليه قصيره جدا مما تؤدي في بعض
الحالات الى اصابته باضرار معينه دعنا
نتابع بعض المشاهد لكتائب القسام في حي
البريج نعم تلك المشاهد التي حصلت عليها
الجزيره نتابع المشاهد ثم نعلق عليها
طيب دبابه ميركافا هذه لا نعم الان هي
المشاهد في مخيم
البريج الان انا شاهدت الفيلم هذا سابقا
شخص شخصان الشخص الاول هو حامل القاذف
والاخر هو قام بدور مزدوج بدور مسؤول
الاستطلاع المساعد لانه في نهايه بعد
التفجير تم استخدام
اي الرشاش الاوتوماتيكي من اجل الاجهاز
على من نج من العمليه هذه هنا عمليه
استهداف الدبابه من المنطقه الخلفيه اذا
لاحظنا بال ياسين 105 ياسين 105 مداه
اي الفعال والمؤثر 130 متر قد يصل الى 150
لكن يفضل استخدامه على مسافه 130 متر فما
دون وهذا كان من داخل المناطق المبنيه لكن
بصوره مختلفه والمو والمكان اللي اللي
اطلق منه الصاروخ ليس كما هو في الشمال
هناك كثافه البناء كانت من داخل الابنيه
هنا كان في الخارج هذه اللقطه هذه اللقطه
تم استهداف ناقله النمر وهذا كان في
الخارج هذا يثبت ما نقول بانه كان في
المنطقه الزراعيه شرق مد مخيم البريج كانت
الارض مفتوحه وتحرك ضمن الارض الزراعيه
نعم
طيب ايضا اضافه الى الى هذه الصور كان
هناك ايضا اليوم تطور لافت الاعلان عن
استخدام صاروخ سام سب نعم ضد طائره اباتشي
نعم هذا هو المره الثانيه كان هناك
استخدام صاروخ سام 18 سام 18 وسام س هو
اقل يعني كفاءه لا اقول تاثيرا اقل كفاءه
صاروخ سام 18 ي صل مداه في زاويه 45 الى
ما يقارب 5 كيلو ارتفاع عمودي 3 ونص كيلو
لا هذا مواصفاته اقل الحشوه اقل لكنه فاعل
بس يبقى نقطه اساسيه يجب ان نشير لها ان
الاباتشي صواريخها ه الفيار مداها 11 م
شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري وشكرا
للمتابعه مشاهدينا ختام هذه النافذه
العسكريه الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على غزه